the joe biden administration has already
done
so much that i want to spend time today
focusing on that but we should talk
about the inauguration which happened
yesterday
it was notable in that it was very
different
than past inaugurations for a number of
reasons it took place during a global
hundred year pandemic and so the crowd
was
very very small and the entire national
mall which would often be filled with
people
to different degrees depending on which
inauguration we're talking about as we
know the crowd size
of inaugurations has been a flash point
in the past uh empty with flags instead
um the outgoing president wasn't there
for the first time in 152 years donald
trump fleeing washington dc for palm
beach florida
early in the morning yesterday but joe
biden was sworn in
there were no incidents of violence
there were no arrests or
unrest in the area just the new
presidency and vice president kamala
harris being sworn in here um
supreme court justice sonia sotomayor
does mispronounce kamala's name as
kamala
no one's perfect i expect that there
will be much of that in the next few
years
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me i
kamala davey harris do solemnly swear
i kamala davey harris i solemnly swear
that i will support and defend
the constitution of the united states
that i will support
and defend the constitution of the
united states against
all enemies foreign and domestic against
all
enemies born and domestic that i will
bear true
faith and allegiance to the same that i
will bear true faith and allegiance to
the same
that i take this obligation freely that
i take this obligation freely
without any mental reservation or
purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge
that i will well and faithfully
discharge the duties of the office on
which i am about to enter
the duties of the office upon which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god
and then joe biden also sworn in by the
chief justice of the supreme court john
roberts
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear
that i will faithfully execute that i
will faithfully execute
the office of president of the united
states office of president of the united
states
and will to the best of my ability the
world to the best of my ability
preserve protect and defend preserve
protect and defend
the constitution of the united states
constitution of the united states so
help you god
so help me god congratulations mr
president
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so there it is trump out biden in biden
giving a speech focused
on unity the rea the the pragmatic
uh reality is there will likely not be
the unity biden
calls for but biden calling for it
not mentioning trump once but mentioning
the big challenges that lie ahead of the
country
for the country including starting to be
respected again by the world
uh dealing with the virus and more here
is joe biden talking about that
i know speaking of unity can sound to
some like a foolish fantasy these days
i know the forces that divide us are
deep and they are real
but i also know they are not new
our history has been a constant struggle
between the american ideal that we're
all are created equal
and the harsh ugly reality that racism
nativism fear demonization
have long torn us apart biden
directly attacking the deceptive
and pernicious disinformation that has
become
standard during trumpian america
about which during which we saw facts
manufactured every disagreement
doesn't have to be a cause for total war
and we must reject the culture in which
facts themselves
are manipulated and even manufactured
now former vice president mike pence at
the inauguration
not clapping on that one and during many
others and why would he
biden is pointing directly to him not
with his finger but with his words
and it is pence and trump and their
supporters and media allies
that did the manufacturing of many of
those so-called facts
joe biden then telling the folks that
did not
support him that he will also be their
president and asking them to hear him
out
to all those who supported our campaign
i'm humbled by the faith you've placed
in us
to all those who did not support us let
me say this
hear me out as we move forward take a
measure of me and my heart
if you still disagree so be it
that's democracy that's america
the right to dissent peaceably then the
guard rails of our republic is perhaps
this nation's
greatest strength yet hear me clearly
this agreement must not lead to this
union
and i pledge this to you i will be a
president for
all americans all americans
and then joe biden saying we will repair
our alliances of course the reason these
alliances need
repair is that they were destroyed by
the trump administration
biden doesn't say that but it certainly
implied we all understand
the world is watching watching all of us
today
so here's my message of those beyond our
borders
america has been tested and we've come
out stronger for it
we will repair our alliances and engage
with the world once again
not to meet yesterday's challenges but
today's and tomorrow's challenges
so this was the right speech for the
right moment and
very quickly i mean almost instantly in
a sense
we shifted from the ceremonial
to the logistical and to getting things
done there are so many things
desperately needed and shockingly
overdue right now
that there's quite literally no time
to bask in the afterglow of the
inauguration and the afterglow of the
fireworks
the literal afterglow because there's so
much that needs to get done and that's
exactly what i want to talk about next
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called teddy stratford i love
these shirts and that's why i asked them
to be a sponsor of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because all of their shirts come
with a patented
zipper hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but most importantly
just overall it makes the shirt fit much
better
and look better the carefully designed
shirt
is also cut in a way that improves the
look of your upper body physique it has
a really nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout